prenatal care is essential to deliver a
healthy baby
but what if you don't have access to
medical care well staff and students
over at turtle university are trying to
change that bianca holmen live this
morning with that story bianca good
morning to you
hey good morning alex good morning john
so like you said prenatal health care is
so important to deliver a healthy baby
and to ensure the health of the mother
uh and so tour university they have that
mobile bus that goes out into the
community and so they're bringing this
health care to
the women experiencing homelessness it's
a new partnership between torah
university and united healthcare
foundation and to tell us more about
just the educational component component
and how important it is for the students
here
i'm joined by dr gilliard so tell us
more about how this is going to
influence
our next generations of ob gyn
absolutely it's a coming together of
three factors
that really will hopefully bring this to
fruition
our students from the first year will
have in the curriculum
the idea of what it means to have
maternal health care women's health care
going forward
but more the third component in addition
to providing health care
is also the technology and we have the
latest technology
using ultrasound yeah well let's take a
look at it we got two students who
decide to wake up early
on their time off they could be sleeping
and we know our med students don't get a
lot of sleep but
these ladies woke up so this is the uh
mobile
sonograms that they can do tell us more
these are the latest
versions of something called handheld
ultrasounds focus
and because it gets directly they carry
it like a stethoscope
and it is really the enhanced technology
in the pocket
and they can bring this to the patient
and as you can see it
will be projected onto their phone and
from there it can be projected anywhere
to experts to colleagues
and this is an incredible technology
because as you see there are no wires
attached to it anymore yeah well this is
incredible because again we're used to
seeing again that big monitor the mom's
laying
down and then going to that medical
office but this again brings it directly
to our women
experiencing homelessness so thank you
so much for sharing this with us we know
this is going to benefit
our valley so much to bring healthy
babies into our valley